hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his essay a conscient approach to
business ethics norman bowie is going to
show us how the categorical imperative
in its second formulation applies
particularly within business settings to
the issue of meaningful work and he
derives this from considering the the
full extent of the second formulation so
we should remind ourselves what is the
second formulation according to kant it
runs like this act always so as to treat
humanity in your own person and that of
others
never as a mere means but always as an
end and we can reduce this down to
treating people as ends not just mere
means that is respecting their human
dignity
and their autonomy this has not just a
sort of negative aspect selling telling
us that we can't do
certain things like coerce people
or
make them act in conditions of ignorance
deceive them
there's also a positive side to it for
kant there's what we call positive
freedom which is
another version of our autonomy which
has to do with the development of human
capacities we have positive freedom when
we are not restricted from or when we're
even you know supported in or or
fostered in developing our distinctively
human capacities and we might say well
what are those
bowie is going to talk in particular
about rational and moral capacities so
rational capacities are our ways of
thinking things out and these aren't
just theoretical they're also practical
and here's where we get to the moral our
our capacity for for example to
develop certain habits good habits that
help us become better people that would
be a moral capacity the ability to
view things from another person's
perspective and understand their
vulnerabilities
which some people call empathy that's
one version of it that could be a moral
capacity
so bowie applies this to the issue of
meaningful work a very big problem
within the contemporary workplace is it
not and he says that conscient ethics
would require
companies to provide meaningful work so
defined and then he gives us a sort of
bullet point list of what meaningful
work would look like and it's worth
dwelling on each of these bullet points
in turn so the first one actually
includes two things he says it's freely
chosen right so
this would rule out the sort of wealth
take the job or get the hell out of here
uh you're gonna you're gonna accept
whatever it is that we give you sort of
attitudes um the difference between some
companies in in today's workplace right
it has to be freely chosen
so this would rule out companies say
going into impoverished areas and
offering very reduced wages for those
employees or bad work conditions
wouldn't it
provides worker opportunity to exercise
autonomy on the job autonomy means the
capacity to choose for oneself so this
would not only include things like being
given work that you then get to decide
what to do within the the structure of
company policies so you know if you
happen to come in and you don't like
word and you prefer uh you know google
docs and the company works with
microsoft well you're going to work with
microsoft but you know you could still
exercise some autonomy on how you set up
your your memos for example
how you arrange the time spent on the
tasks that you have rather than being
micromanaged
down to the the very minute or something
like that when you get to take bathroom
breaks good example as well
supports autonomy and rationality right
supports the autonomy and rationality of
human beings he says work that lessens
autonomy or that undermines rationality
is immoral so work that requires you to
do something stupid irrational for hours
on end
that would be undermining your
rationality there's other ways of
undermining autonomy as well this would
rule out for example
workplace harassment and bullying
wouldn't it
another key thing
how are you paid
what is a fair wage
from a conscient perspective so bowie
says there's three components to this
provides a salary sufficient to do three
things
to exercise independence provide for
physical well-being and satisfaction of
some of the workers desires so let's
start at the the last one first right
he's not saying that you have to pay
people so much that they can satisfy all
of their desires i mean
as autonomous beings they're responsible
for their desires some of them sometimes
desires can be really out of whack can't
they
but you should certainly make it
possible for them to satisfy some of
their desires so they're not just
working your job and another job
so that they can barely make ends meet
which would be you know sort of the the
second condition provide for physical
well-being that means being able to eat
it also means being able to go to the
doctor when you need to it also means
not being so stressed out about work
uh or whether you're gonna be laid off
or you know the the write-up that you
got that you can actually get you know
good eight hours of sleep when you need
it all of those sorts of things the
other one independence employees should
be paid enough
that if they're prudent they can acquire
savings and
do something else than work for you
maybe work for another firm
change their
trajectory and work for in a different
sector get an education
or become entrepreneurs
any of those
we should also include uh being able to
retire on time all of those should be
part of the salary if this was actually
applied people would probably be paid
quite a lot more by most corporations
enables a worker to develop rational
capacities this is important this is
beyond just supporting
rational capacities this is now about
enabling them to develop that so having
a clear promotion and responsibilities
structure within the organization would
seem to be part of that rather than
saying well you're you're you know
classified as factory worker you're
going to stay factory worker till you
die
you know allowing people to cross train
helping people to move slowly into
leadership positions those are
developing rational capacities
so a good workplace would actually do
that
not interfering with workers moral
development
so not requiring people
to do things that they know are immoral
not causing what we call moral damage to
them you know when for example you know
let's say you work for a collections
agency and you're given a quota that you
have to meet each day and the best way
to meet that quota is by engaging in
deceptive or coercive practices
well from a conscient perspective you
are being
forced into a situation where either you
lose the job or you do things that you
know are wrong
and
that's
fundamentally problematic that's that's
interfering with one's moral development
perhaps even setting it back
now from a conscient perspective the
manager would actually have two sets of
obligations
all of these things would be be parts of
meaningful work and so managers have a
requirement to provide meaningful work
now can you make the entire company
provide meaningful work
no you have to work within the area that
you have so you know your direct reports
for example you would try to provide
them with meaningful work the people
underneath you as well
you would try to foster that there's
also another obligation to try to move
the company in a better direction
create a certain kind of organization as
as bowie says says a discussion of what
a conscient business firm would look
like leads directly into other
considerations that have to do with what
this organization would resemble
you